hello everybody and welcome back to game
review today on game review I wanted to
go over a game by a chess player from
the mid 20th century of course I'm going
over a game of Solomon floor in this
game floor took on a player by the name
of sallow Landau and it is honestly a
wild wild game and I wanted to take you
guys through it here
so for played the move d4 Landau
responded with the move Knight f6 and
then we have c4 c6 and this is a pretty
interesting way to transpose into the
Slav defense it does avoid some specific
things and it does grant black some
extra options depending on the one for
example if white tries to play the move
Bishop f4 here well you might run into
d5 and if C takes d5 sorry you might not
run into D 5 D 5 is what you might
expect but black actually does have an
extra option to play the move Queen b6
here and these lines get a little bit
interesting we had none of that funny
business today though
just Knight f3 and now after d5 we
transpose into a normal Slav structure
white chose the quite variation with the
move III and there's actually a lot of
different ways that this can go from
here for white a lot of different ways
for white to play in the game he kind of
took a more conservative approach floor
just says after e6 is going to be happy
developing these pieces one at a time
Knight PD to Bishop e7 Bishop d3 Knight
bt7
we have castles and castles and now
floor just plays the move b3 he's gonna
get this bish about to be 2 and he's
happy with his nice little structure
that he constructed here with all of his
pieces having very natural squares to go
to so in the game his opponent Landau
decided now was the time to break with
the move c5 and whenever you see all of
these puns kind of stuck together on the
Queen side like this you can expect some
very specific pawn structures to kind of
arise from these positions you can get a
variety of structures one of
for example if we see takes and takes
would be the classic isolated Queens
pawn structure this is one option you
might also just see all the puns blow up
like this this is another option you
might also see white ignore this tension
as he did in the game with Bishop d2
Bishop b2 and from there
you can get what's known as the hanging
pawn structure after takes and takes
these two pawns are known as hanging
pawns of course in this case hanging
does not mean that they are you know on
priests or anything that they can be
captured it means they're kind of
hanging together there's no pawns on and
either of the files surrounding these
pawns and so these pawns are kind of out
on their own hanging out together and
they will be trying to defend each other
and it's a pretty common structure from
positions like these in general when
these pawns are standing right next to
each other it is going to be a pretty
nice structure for white just for
example if white ever had to play a move
like c5 all of a sudden the structure is
a lot less comfortable for white because
now you do get left with a slightly
backward pawn if there weren't already
immediate like tactical problems with it
you would just rather have these pawns
kind of next to each other for the
moment guarding a lot of squares in the
game black plays the move b6 which does
a nice job of controlling the squares in
front of the pawns now Queen c2 by
whites and we kind of start to see the
advantage of having these hanging pawns
while they can be attacked by the
opponent they do control a lot of
central squares here and with the slight
edge in central space white is going to
try and launch an initiative actually on
the Kings side Bishop d7 and now white
does in fact make use of this extra
space he has in this extra space that he
has by playing the move Knight to e5 now
in the game apply played the move Queen
D c7 and in this position I would like
you guys at home to top to stop take a
second and try to figure out how you can
best continue here with white there's
one move in particular that I think
really does allow white to play it for
an advantage with
a very very strong initiative okay
hopefully you got it
and that move of course is the move F
for this is the move that starts
launching the King side attack in full
force it supports this knight on e5 and
it even prepares to start thinking about
opening the F file and getting this
truck into the game now from here black
play the move rook F to d8 black is
looking for counter play against these
central pawns of course they're not
defended by any other pumps and so they
can't be attacked they can be viewed as
a slight weakness and that's how black
is playing for counter play against
floor in this case though Knight d2 f-35
floor just bringing more pieces into the
attack h6
is how black chose to respond trying to
keep an eye on this g5 Square also
removing this pawn from any threat of
capture by this Bishop sitting here on
d3 in the game floor plays very very
calmly very naturally very this is this
is kind of the meat of attacking chess
right like you know everybody loves the
flashy sacrifices but it's moves in
positions like these that set up the
attack that are really where the best
attacking players shine and so you see
so far our floor just plays very very
natural moves he just starts bringing
more pieces over to the Kings side and
it continues doing that here you know
this Queen it's fine on c2 but it's even
better on e too when it can jump to
squares like kief or jump out to squares
on the Kings side at a later date and
help support a 5 as well it's moves like
we need to that are really the the thing
that defines a strong attacking player
these moves
setting up the attack the move Knight
takes e5 was now played by the opponent
land out and after F takes e5 white
really does have a very very strong
advantage here the move 97 comes on the
board and now once again I'd like you
guys at home to pause for a moment try
and find the best way to continue with
white there is one move in particular
that really starts opening things up
starts crushing the opponent immediately
you know floor it played all these nice
preparatory most bring in the Queen over
bringing the knight over
opening up the F file but now is the
time to open things up time to go get
the opponent okay hopefully you found it
that move of course is this move D 5 D 5
a really really killer blow starting to
break down the structure on the kingside
of course if you dare to capture this
pawn you're gonna be met with this movie
6 and this is just going to be
devastating for you if you capture this
pawn Queen takes c6 is actually just
going to be checkmate in three with
Queen geez Queen f7 mate or if you
prefer Bishop g6 mate or if you prefer
Queen g6 mate so you absolutely cannot
capture this pawn if you try a little
bit harder you still end up getting
destroyed by this pawn on f7 so no takes
on d5 for black instead Bishop c5 check
is this choice now King h1
he takes d5 is played now and once again
it is white to move and win now there
are a few ways are actually maybe just a
couple ways to win here for whites but I
really like the move and that white came
up with in the game
it's just absolutely crushing and it's a
very very very beautiful move okay
hopefully you guys at home came up with
some stuff here of course the movie six
is going to be winning in this position
as well believe this was points initial
idea and it does still hold true here
and you know e six probably would have
been beautiful enough to make for a
notable game you know the game could
continue it with Knight f8 and then you
know you can play any number of moves
you know 95 even and after it takes for
example takes on f7 and you're just kind
of getting crushed but the move played
in the game is even fancier than that
rather than playing East 68th
floor actually plays this move Knight g5
and this is just such a beautiful move
you just place this knight entirely on
crease of course you know it might not
be totally necessary because e 6 is
winning but usually when you see a
knight sacrifice like this the point is
the fact that
like you know you're opening up some
h-file right you have like a pawn on h4
you open up the H file and your rut
comes into play in this case it is just
purely a clearance sacrifice if you
capture this Knight
you're gonna get met with a six now and
now no matter what you play Queen h5 is
going to be devastating for example the
move d4 we do not play a takes f7 here
but rather just playing Queen to h5
immediately and these are just
unstoppable threats by white if you take
on g2 this might be your only hope
hoping for King takes g2 when Queen c6
might actually save you but just king g1
from white is the refutation to this
idea it's just really incredible stuff
here in the game black unfortunately did
not capture this night allowing all
these beautiful lines instead you know
the side bonus of 95
besides you know allowing your knight to
be captured is you do attack this pawn
on f7 and black simply allowed white to
crash through on the f7 square but
really all the crazy fun lines come
after H takes g5 here against anything
else you know the f7 pawn is just
hanging oh yeah aged 6 g v e6
and now this threat of queen h5 is just
going to be unstoppable if Knight of
fate still eat takes f7 though in Queen
age 5 just cannot stop this threat
there's no way in in the game though
tonight f8 no Knight takes f7 is good
riki eights queen up to g4 continues the
attack quite nicely
rook up to e6 is trying to defend but
now the move Bishop f5 hits this guy
rook over to e8 is sacrificing some
material we just take it with the white
pieces and go 96 and this game is is
just pretty much over at this point not
a ton that black can do here to get back
into the game
he tried trading off this powerful
Knight but after a takes d6 and Queen d7
of course if you capture this guy you
run into checkmates if you capture this
guy like this you run into Bishop e5 so
Queen d7 forced by black now Bishop a3
defends this powerful pawn Knight up to
h7 and now just the column h3
you know white is up in a
Jane Shearer has a powerful d6 pawn he
knows his position is winning so he just
takes the time to play some Knights
improving moves D takes c4 Queen takes
d4 now night up to f6 and now another
fun move by white here not content to
settle for you know his current winning
position these sacrifices the exchanged
back with Rua takes f6 just because just
because G takes f6 now and the move rook
e1 is quite nice hitting this guy bishop
see it the only real move to stay in the
game here if you play the move king f7
you're gonna get met with rook takes c6
I mean takes c6 Queen c7 check picking
up this bishop so Bishop c6 mercier
instead now look back over to c1 Bishop
e7 we see a rookie g4 check King h8 and
now after rook c7 the game is actually
going to be over rook e1 is check King
h2 but after Queen takes g4 forced due
to all this pressure h6g for this Bishop
is hanging and this pawn is promoting
and there's no way to stop both threats
for example you save the Bishop d7 or if
d1 there should be seven and queening
will be coming so this was a very
impressive game by floor I had a lot of
fun going over this one the move Knight
g5 is just such a beautiful move
hopefully you guys enjoyed it I had a
lot of fun going over it today on game
review once again my name is Kayla Denby
thank you very much for joining me and I
will see you next time